Google cast is all about
enabling multi-screen
experiences for the living room.
It uses a sender/receiver
topology that works like this.
You already have an app on Android,
iOS, or the web.
That's your sender.
You start by integrating the cast SDK
to enable discovery of cast
devices on the local network.
When your app finds a nearby device,
it makes the cast icon
visible to your users.
This nearby cast device could be
a Chromecast or even an AndroidTV.
It's the receiver.
The user will touch the cast
icon on the sender and
select the cast device to send or
cast stuff to the big screen.
What's actually happening here is
the sender's telling the cast device
to load a particular
receiver application.
The Cast device then pulls that in from
the web since it's just an HTML 5 app
written in HTML, CSS, and JavaScript.
It could be a simple media receiver that
plays a stream directly from the cloud,
or a custom receiver such as a game.
You can also send messages from your app
to the receiver app to control things
like play, pause, volume and more.
And that's it.
A quick and
simple overview of Google Cast.
We'll cover more detail in
the Google Cast STK and
receiver apps a little later on.